mais qu'est ce que tu vas imaginer là
maintenant ma chérie mais puisque je te
dis que c'est l'infirmière de gilbert je
les ai commandé ce matin en sortant qui
les aura demain soir en rentrant ce
thème
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas de femme jackie non
monsieur bah alors une femme ça
s'entretient
sinon adieu jolie candy monsieur
adieu
c'est un
[Musique]
paris
joli
moi
ces longues
des jamais
on allait
non
c'est amusant
adieu championne
et
une écrire
tu le dis
[Musique]
mais l'ombre
ça va
et
il était père de prince
mais
m
lee
tél
alors jean françois michaël bonsoir
bonsoir
alors adieu jolie candy c'était en
quelle année 1968 témoin qui a écrit
radio jury quentin du génie quand on dit
c'est un monsieur qui s'appelle raymond
janot il ya l'autre s'appelle le
franquart veille et alain boublil qui
est la révolution française qui on doit
aussi les misérables
ça s'est vendu à combien de 2 millions
d'exemplaires je suis incapable de te
dire parce que je les enregistrais dans
cinq ou six langues
à mon avis on a dû avoisiner les 3 4 ou
5 millions mais quand même oui je suis
parti en italie en espagne en allemagne
au japon
j'ai fait le tour du monde c'était
rapporter combien toit après ça m'a
rapporté d'abord la stone martin de que
j'ai absolument veut acheter donc de
cotiser de goldfinger une petite rolls
et puis ça m'a rapporté le fait d'être
très très heureux pendant des années à
des cadeaux aux amis
ouais tu es mon métier tu as dit je suis
passé du solex à la rolls oui tout à
fait sûr que nos solex jeu tu as
commencé très jeunes enfants l'âge de 9
ans à l'âge de 9 ans tu te tais à
l'alhambra déjà l'alhambra sur les
genoux de matéri et je vantais les
pastilles valda c'est-à-dire à dire je
devais faire ma d'assez bons amants oui
ça comment ces jeunes
oui oui et je me cachais dans l'alhambra
parce que je voulais toujours assisté à
au concert de zizi jeanmaire de plus
deux boeing de roland petit est alors à
18 ans tu étais le chauffeur de barbara
donc j'avais vraiment envie de réussir
dans le chai le faisais je vais raconter
non j'étais chauffeur de barbara parce
que ma soeur sur l'équipe à l'époque est
alors j'étais le chauffeur mais le plus
mauvais chauffeur et un jour avec
barbara g l'anecdote on était à orly
elle arrivait babar a eu un malaise
elle est tombée par terre je n'ai pas
relevé j'ai pas aussi con
tu as commencé par faire trois disques
raté sous le nom de yves rooses de la
bossa nova
ouais ça marchait pas du tout a pas du
tout ça intéresse pas du tout et puis un
jour un directeur artistique ta
conseillé de changer de nom comment ça
s'est passé et non j'ai choisi un nom
ouais le plus plus beau en ce nom ça m'a
pris la nuit
jean françois michaël faut dire que le
mexique d'être très à la mode des
prénoms et puis on pensait pas du tout
que ça marcherait et c'est au mois de
juillet on a commencé à m'appeler en
disant tu sais que tu vends beaucoup tu
vois beaucoup j'ai eu c'est formidable
ça va me poser quelques problèmes à la
rentrée quand même quand je vais revenir
on a travaillé dans la maison ouais bah
oui parce qu'à l'époque j'avais en même
temps what is why ted michel delpech
oui tu étais le producteur le directeur
artistique à l'époque j'étais directeur
artistique j'aidais mon travail donc
chez barclay et c'était très embêtant
d'être tous les deux numéros 1 sans que
l'on sache qui était l'autre mais tu
t'es arrêté pourquoi enfin j'ai au bout
de cinq ans et j'en avais vraiment là
qui vous alors ça marche forcée de il ya
deux ans il y en a qui disent que en
fait il s'est arrêté parce que ça
marchait pas ouais moi je le dirai pas
parce que
le crois pas c'est un peu vrai et puis
et puis en fait c'est pas pour ça c'est
parce que ça me plaisait plus ouais non
plus du tout parce qu'il ya un côté qui
est déplaisant c'est que les gens te
reconnaissent partout tu peux pas vivre
normalement
une fois que tu l'as vécu très fort
c'est bien le vivre une fois et après il
faut retourner un peu l'anonymat abbas
attend ben était vraiment qu'on vient de
demander des autographes que non ce
n'est pas le trouver des plages déclare
yves au restaurant de ça c'est pas très
gênant way trouver des places dans les
avions d'affaires s'imaginant ce qui est
gênant c'est c'est après d'être
conscient finalement 2-2 les gens te
reconnaissent mais en fait ils
reconnaissent pas pour ce que tu es
tombé temps quand on a d'autres choses à
dire et donc les affaires et loire après
les problèmes ont commencé
parce que tu as fait la prison un moment
non oui mais c'est quoi l'histoire
l'histoire si je marque c'est une
société qui était ex ps et mr après tout
à fait mais je m'en rappelle plus quand
tu vas me le dire que tu avais emprunter
100 mille francs à quelqu'un a bien
d'autres pour monter une société docteur
tout à fait état jamais monté la société
asi la société a été montée mais le
papier du greffe a été perdu voilà et tu
as fait 34 jours de prison tout à fait
c'est dur j'ai revu encore qu'une
journée avant
oui parce que je recevais des je
recevais des convocations et je n'y
allais pas un jour donc la convocation
est arrivé je suis pas allé et je
voulais pas dire où je t'aime ce que je
voulais pas m
les gens quittent avec moi on est venu
me chercher comment comme ces mois de
juillet vous y rester et puis quand le
juge est arrivé le premier au démon mois
d'août et d'impartition à sa sortie de
l'eau le jour même et quand tu étais en
prison tu regrettait pas quand même
d'avoir un petit peu méprisé là le fait
d'être star le fait d'être reconnu par
tout ça ils m'ont retenu l'incroyable et
une autre du après tu étais malade
oui j'étais malade on s'est foutu fumait
beaucoup de cigarettes vous je continue
je fais mes deux trois paquets par jour
vous avez un cancer de la gorge ou un
départ oui mais j'étais a pas arrêté de
fumer
non en fait tu a divorcé à cette époque
si oui c'est ma niveau le même quand
même oui oui ou si c'est pareil c'est
paniquant sinon c'est pas beaucoup c'est
la vie pas plus flipper que ça qui
certainement mais je m'en rappelle pas
tu veux pas tant râpé non c'est pas que
je veux pas me rappeler c'est que c'est
il ya eu tellement de bonnes choses que
finalement non et comment tu te n'est
sorti de cette époque c'est-à-dire
cancer prison séparation de ta femme
plafond la musique j'ai toujours avec la
musique on peut toujours tout faire
alors après justement ça a très bien
marché
voyons de producteurs oui je reproduis
stéphanie de monaco à belle aventure de
stefanie tu as rencontré comment cette
famille voici au départ bon j'avais une
chanson qui s'appelait ouragans ouais et
puis les gens bizarres ça c'est pour ces
familles là tu sais ça et pourquoi pas
pour le pape
évidemment c'était impossible et puis
j'ai eu la chance de les rencontrer on
s'est rencontré un jour on a parlé tous
les deux je lui ai dit si tu veux tu
viens faire un essai ce soir à l'époque
j'avais connu j'avais une fiat 500 jeudi
ben écoutez je passe vous prendrez vous
et puis je vous emmène et puis bon
j'allais dans un studio qui s'appelle
sur marcadet et donc sur la porte de la
chapelle puis je dis vous suivez et puis
j'étais tellement nombreux nuages et
finalement je suis arrivé la bretelle de
beauvais et suivait toujours alors que
ses dépens de la chapelle crise de nerfs
et au final on est revenue en arrière
elle s'est mis à chanter et on s'est
plus quittés pendant deux ans sacré
champion véritable et tu veux dit là ce
soir c'est t elle bien sûr c'était
n'était pas au reste c'est à dire que
pour ouragan il ya eu des choristes qui
ont chanté avec elle le refrain elle a
chanté les couplets mais dans tout
l'album c'est une vraie joie et comment
tu expliques après quelques morceaux en
très très bien marché d'un seul coup et
se soit complètement écroulé au niveau
showbiz s'est pas écoulé on s'est
quittés par amour
c'est à dire qu'il est tombé amoureux de
quelqu'un et qu'elle a préféré choisir
sa vie ce qu'elle cherche toujours
recherchée elle a trouvé l'amour est un
art était l'ami maintenant qu'est ce que
tu fais toujours commencé à chanter
ouais parce que tu sors un disque à la
rentrée la des chansons nous est sorti
j'ai sorti j'ai refait toutes mes
anciennes chansons parce que je me suis
aperçu que pour ça faisait 25 ans que je
cachais dans un petit coin de mon coeur
le chanteur il existe quand même le
monde quand vie comme peut l'être un peu
qu'on le reconnaisse a comme un petit
peu doit revivre un peu tard commence
oui ça recommence c'est normal parce que
sinon je vais à projeter tout ce que
j'ai de mauvaises sur les gens je vais
produire demain non comme je vais de
nouveau très équilibré à l'époque donc
quand ça a très bien marché s'est
ensuite moins bien marché comment tu as
vécu ce changement de situation comment
tuer je vais passer de l'un à l'autre
à l'époque
bon c'est vrai il ya un moment que c'est
très très difficile parce qu'on regarde
autour si on nous reconnaît encore et
finalement s'aperçoit du tout alors on
se dit que finalement les plus grand
chose et puis c'est ça qui est très très
dur
tu as quel âge 45 ans les cours est sûr
de ne rien rater de l'inaptitude abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu